Elon Musk is one of the most influential
and successful person of our time
musk is a role model for many and many
people look up to him
here are some traits that can be found
in musk that has contributed to his Fame
and success
one passion
passion is one of the key traits that
has contributed to elon's success
musk is known for being deeply
passionate about the work he does and
this passion is contagious
it inspires those around him to be
equally dedicated and motivated and it
helps to drive him to achieve great
things
musk's passion is evident in everything
he does
whether he is working on one of his many
companies such as Tesla or SpaceX or
speaking at conferences and events he
exudes a sense of enthusiasm and
excitement that is infectious
this passion has helped him to build a
loyal following of supporters and fans
who believe in his vision and are
willing to work hard to help him achieve
it
furthermore musk's passion is not just
limited to his work
he is also passionate about technology
science and the future of humanity
he often speaks about his long-term
goals such as colonizing Mars and making
Humanity a multi-planetary species and
his passion for these ideas is palpable
in short musk's passion is one of his
greatest strengths and it is a key
reason for his success
it drives him to work hard to take risks
and to pursue his goals with
determination
2. vision
musk's vision is another key trait that
has contributed to his success
musk is known for his ability to see the
potential of new technologies and to
Envision how they can be used to improve
the world
this forward-thinking approach has
allowed him to develop Innovative
products and services that have
disrupted entire Industries
musk's Vision can be seen in many of his
companies and projects
for example with Tesla he saw the
potential for electric vehicles to
replace gas-powered cars and he has
worked tirelessly to bring this Vision
to fruition
with SpaceX he has a vision for making
Humanity a multi-planetary species and
he has developed technology and plans to
make this a reality
furthermore musk's Vision extends Beyond
just his businesses
he also has a vision for the future of
humanity and he often speaks about his
ideas for advancing technology science
and space exploration
this long-term thinking has helped him
to inspire others and to build a
following of supporters who believe in
his vision and are willing to work hard
to help him achieve it
3. determination
musk is known for his unwavering
determination and his ability to
persevere through challenges
he has faced many obstacles in his
career but he has always remained
focused and committed to achieving his
goals
musk's determination can be seen in many
of his companies and projects
for example with Tesla he faced many
challenges including production delays
competition from other automakers and
skepticism from investors
but he never lost sight of his goal of
creating a successful electric vehicle
company and he worked tirelessly to
overcome these obstacles and bring his
vision to life
furthermore musk's determination is
evident in his personal life as well
he has faced many personal challenges
including divorce and the loss of a
child but he has always remained focused
and driven
this determination has allowed him to
overcome these difficult experiences and
to push him to pursue his goals
thank you for watching
subscribe for more